myron i have a question for you
negative blips a channel member says
trainable dude you just alerted every
feminist on the internet is this a
is this a useful clip that maybe ryan
can use to get some math on tick tock
like you know train women do you think
that'll work is it is it
on uh as soon as i say anything about
like you know
dealing women punishing bad behavior i
just get a buncha
and it's like bruh like you know
what it is well like you know i always
like
it's like women don't know what they
want they want like a guy that earns a
lot of money
but at the same time they want an equal
partnership they want a guy who's
dominant but they also want to say oh i
want to be able to you know
have a 50 50 partnership and it's like
it doesn't work that way but the problem
is that
women i always say men live in a
fact-based reality where your
performance
creates your reality women live in a
bizarro [ __ ] world where
and no matter what they do how mediocre
they are uh
whatever crazy belief system they have
they're appreciated for and a praise for
it
a fat guy gets clowned on hey you're a
fat ass you're a lardo
you need a hahaha a woman that's fat
it's okay baby love your curves body
positivity
so since women live in a world where
there's zero consequences to their bad
actions
they say dumb stuff like this where oh
trainable what are you talking about
because they're not used to being ever
held by standards so a guy like me comes
around and says
punish bad behavior oh my god this guy's
nuts he's saying punish bad behavior for
women like it's the knights
yeah like a dog you know what i'm saying
and it's like
it is don't talk [ __ ] about dogs they're
noble creatures
byron's next tech talk will be
you know who dianna fleischman is
obviously oh yeah yeah
diana fleischmann is a sort of evo psych
behavioral psych uh you know she's a
doctor i should say dr diana fleischmann
right
she has done these uh series of talks i
don't know if there are ted talks but
certainly at like on the college level
and they were titled how to train your
boyfriend
right how to like behaviorally condition
your boyfriend
and this is something i've been
interested in for a long time because
that's my background in behavioral
psychology so i was like
how is it that that's cool but but if a
guy were to say oh train you're
like we were just saying a minute ago
like feminists are supposed to lose
their mind if you if you talk about that
but yet it's fine for women to say oh
i'm going to train my boyfriend
but in the next breath they go and they
say exactly what myron is saying which
is
uh i want a guy who is dominant taller
than me
six pack abs six figure income you know
six six six right i want the guy who's
like all that
and but they don't but they never it's
like that that
cognitive dissonance never make they
never make that connection right there
because what they really they don't
really know what they want
like children right you don't know what
is best for you
and so a guy with a dominant competent
guy
to explain those things to you the
unfortunate fact is that we live in a
gynocentric social order
so me just expressing that or even
saying you don't know what's best for
you
i do know what's best for you for me to
say that now we're out of the
sort of equalist globalist uh blank
slate
you know social constructionists crap
and now i'm the misogynist
chauvinist [ __ ] for actually having
to express that myron can you give us
the story time sound bite please i have
a story for this yeah
i got you right now baby
at a time not not too long ago but a
long time ago
there was this girl that i broke up with
who called me to say goodbye
and i said to her well where are you
going are you off to japan to leave for
good finally because i wanted to get rid
of her
she says no i'm going to be taking a
permanent solution to this temporary
problem
she was a succubus as described here
well
you have two choices you can hang up on
her
for the best or you can try to talk her
off that and then hang up on her and
hope for the best
i chose the latter um yeah it's just the
next dude like this is not complicated
it's don't be a [ __ ] and move on and
you know set some for
firm boundaries did you guys want to
chime in on this i'll only decide
scary language only to say that um
somebody else's decisions in this kind
of matter are their
responsibility you are not responsible
ultimately for somebody else making that
decision you know if you if you need to
remove yourself
from a relationship for your own benefit
for whatever reason that's that's your
decision
how they respond to that is is their
decision ultimately so
and that would go for anybody male or
female that that's just how it is so you
you can't be
tied back by by worrying about that um
super chat
saying how to persuade a feminist woman
to drop feminism
if she has potential but has been
brainwashed by the media
this is a great question i want to hit
on this real quick we did a video we did
a podcast where we said
types of women to never take seriously
in a long-term relationship
and feminist was one of them guys and
the reason why i say you don't want to
ever date a feminist or take her
seriously like if you want to smash and
pass cool
but the reason why you don't want to
take her seriously is because quite
frankly
feminism teaches women a lot of bad
habits that are not conducive to a
successful long-term relationship with a
man that's the reality they
it teaches women to like think that
they're your equal to basically absolve
themselves of responsibilities when it's
convenient
for them to say oh i'm a feminist at
this point but i also want me to treat
you uh
but i also want you to you know give me
the traditional chivalry
and the problem is that when she can
flip-flop her roles
versus yours or static you're gonna run
into into a lot of problems with these
type of women man because like i said
before a lot of feminists live in a
bizarre world not a fact-based reality
so these types of women bro i wouldn't
even try to
like get her to drop feminine she ain't
gonna drop it you know when women stop
becoming feminist bro i'll tell you guys
right now
when they start having to pay for their
own [ __ ] drinks at the bar that's
when they realize they got to stop
saying when they stop being feminist and
they realize damn i'm getting older
i want to die what's going on here
that's what's before
there's a flood when there's a hurricane
yes
right water starts cause like girls like
this bro
she's gonna expect you to lay your life
on the line and protect her if there's
physical confrontation but she won't
even make you a sandwich
so you never want to deal with women
like this bro because they have bad
habits that will ruin you and ruin the
relationship in the future so i won't
even take a feminist seriously as far as
the relationship goes
if you if you pick up indicators of a
feminist narrative my advice to you is
to set firm boundaries around it
and make sure that she understands it's
the comply or goodbye narrative if you
don't
like it the front door is over there you
can [ __ ] off so that's one of the
reasons why i leave with the king stuff
is because i like i say i like to
dominate so if the girls are like oh
well do i get a turn when do i get my
turn to dominate like no i'm not i'm not
into that and i'm not attracted to girls
who are
right they'll put a stamp on it right
now
i've noticed that like women who are
like outspokenly
feminists are i don't have problems with
them like
if i go and i lay this stuff out as as
you know
matter of fact as i possibly can it's
not them that i have a problem with it's
guys if i go and i say like you know
men and women are not equal and i can
give you examples as to why the idea of
equality is just nonsense
of course the first thing that that guys
think is that i'm saying that
men are superior i go well depends on
what we're talking about what's the
challenge
is it giving birth well women are
superior at giving birth than men
to to men there's your challenge that's
if that's what we're measuring equality
by
guess what i'm always going to be at a
disadvantage in that in that particular
realm
if we're talking about physical violence
if we're talking about uh
you know protection providing whatever
what's the challenge right
i can go and make those like really
rational kind of pragmatic
you know approaches to like what's equal
and what's not the very fact that i said
that men and women aren't equal
it's not so much women that have the
problem with that because usually if
there's a feminist she doesn't have
any she either doesn't want to talk to
me or she has no other counter argument
but it's the guys who get upset with me
they'll go
what are you saying that men are better
than women no that's not what i'm saying
but it's the guys because they have more
to lose they have more invested in that
that overall um the nice guys
yeah the nice guy thing but they have
more invested in that because they
realize that if
if they are seen even like at a distance
agreeing with with rola tomasi saying
that you know equality doesn't exist
between men and women
then they're they think that they're at
a disadvantage or if they're not going
to be able to relate with women or women
are going to
shun them because you agreed with what i
had to say
you